bier das es in oberfranken mehr als nur
ein getränk
es ist ein lebensgefühl typisch für die
region in bayern sind die vielen
gasthöfe mit eigener brauerei kleine
familienbetriebe wie die brauerei bosch
hier wird das bier von hand gebraut
schon seit mehr als 500 jahren streng
nach reinheitsgebot ohne zusatzstoffe
nur mit verschiedenen sorten hopfen und
malz lässt sich der geschmack des bieres
verändern
kein sud ist genau wie der vorherige er
weiß ganz genau bei welchen zu welcher
zeit welche farbe des ganzen zusammen
die modernen industrie brauchen ist es
ein prozess der bis computer läuft wir
haben keine wir sind die computer
mehrere stunden lang muss der sud aus
wasser und malz kochen dann wird der
hopfen dazu gegeben
kleinste abweichung bei der temperatur
verändern den geschmack des bieres
bierbrauen ist hier mehr als nur
handwerker hat alles seinen festen
rhythmus und dieser rhythmus den
schmeckt man dann auch später im bier
also all das die gefühle der rhythmus
der zeit das gegenüber das macht die
bier gemütlichkeit aus dem der
wettbewerb auf dem biermarkt ist alles
andere als gemütlich das handwerkliche
braunes aufwendiger und teurer als die
industrieproduktion in den
großbrauereien aber die großen diktieren
die preise wir haben den gleichen preis
wie vor zehn jahren
alle anderen kosten sind gestiegen und
damit können sie natürlich hier ein
handwerker die nicht auffangen
deshalb sterben diese kleinen brauereien
dabei kommen viele besucher und
touristen vor allem wegen des guten
bieres nach oberfranken
es gibt mehr als 250 privatbrauereien
vor wenigen jahrzehnten waren es
allerdings noch doppelt so viele
in der familienbrauerei meinl führen die
beiden töchter die tradition fort beide
frauen sind gelernte brauer meisterinnen
und 18.000 hektoliter pro jahr werden
gebraucht meinen bier ist auch in
einigen getränkemärkten in der umgebung
zu haben
auch hier gilt das deutsche
reinheitsgebot experimente mit
zusätzlichen aromen oder gewürzen wollen
die jungen brauerin nicht machen
wir haben uns in 500 jahren eine
technologie arbeite er arbeitet auch an
bildung die seinesgleichen sucht und ich
finde es ist es wäre ein rückschritt zu
sagen wir brauchen jetzt wie alle
anderen ländern mit einem möglichen
zusatzstoffen
die brauerei hat ihre eigenen rezepturen
aus wasser hopfen malz und hefe
nach sechs bis sieben wochen
alkoholischer gärung zeigt sich ob das
bier gelungen ist unser bier muss keiner
großen maße schmecken
also wenn das jetzt in unserem raum
einfacher paar leuten schmeckt und dies
in totaler fan davon
dann sind wir da schon geprüft über und
freuen uns darum kann unser bier mehr
ecken und kanten haben und mussten im
prinzip wie sehr schlank sehr mild seien
zehn verschiedene sorten gibt es helles
dunkles bild weizen oder lager wären mit
viel oder wenig hopfen mit mehr oder
weniger als die mauren wollen möglichst
viele verschiedene geschmäcker treffen
hauptsache es wird nicht langweilig
irgendwas was ein inspirierter zug
genauso in das land andere menschen
andere kultur oder eben neue hopfen die
gastronomie im eigenen gasthof ist für
viele kleine brauereien eine wichtige
einnahmequelle
ein halber liter bier vom fass kostet
bei der brauerei grosch zwischen drei
und vier euro
und dazu gibt es deftige fränkische
küche